hey everyone erik voss here in the new
york stars blue dungeon and we are
reacting as fast as we can to all these
great marvel updates including the
falcon winter soldier first
new big trailer we have seen a trailer
that looks like
it was shot by cap himself because this
is all coming out super fast on the
disney investor day
conference i don't have time to set up
all this you get to see my raw
at the computer desk reaction all this
stuff and then we're going to talk about
some
initial first thoughts i had coming out
of it and then sometime later this
weekend you're going to see
my in-depth frame by frame breakdown of
all the easter eggs that they hid in
this
it's what i do best here it is here's my
reaction
the legacy of that shield is
complicated
the world
it's upside down
merch
people need something to get behind
i need a symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
right just like cap
[Applause]
mean those wings didn't clip nothing
[Music]
hot damn
[Music]
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're i on
fire
what a trailer right like i'm so excited
for this show
so excited to hear that it's coming
march i feel like that is just around
the corner man disney plus is gonna have
these marvel shows coming out one after
the other in 2021
what the time gonna be alive yeah just
like first initial thoughts to this
falcon winter soldier trailer
they are not at all shying away from the
whole legacy of captain america and the
shield what that means and it's
complicated
and by complicated i think they're
hinting at the fact that yeah sam wilson
is not going to be the government's
chosen successor
for captain america neither obviously
will bucky the guy's a freaking fugitive
so the government has their own guy john
walker this is who we see at the
football game i love the shape of the
big old star in the middle of the
football field but what is the conflict
of this series we still don't know when
he says the world is upside down that
could mean a lot of things but we are
getting some looks at what
clearly looks like the thunderbolts
specifically the character
songbird i talked about her in another
video but she can release a
frequency a sonic frequency that lures
in other people and kind of mind
controls them in a way but i love how
she's not alone maybe the whole group of
the thunderbolts they all gonna have
this uh
this mask with a red handprint on it as
if they had been slapped in the face
with
blood and they carry that with them
everywhere they go we see some more
shots of what looks like sam wilson's
farm home
in louisiana we see some spanish moss
hanging on there it's right on the water
i love how the trees look like they're
wrapped up in padding
like it's a way to protect them from
when he's flinging that sword around so
that not all the trees get chopped down
oh we get a shot of baron zemo at some
kind of memorial it has that eagle on it
this could be near sokovia right there
looks like there is a crater filled with
water
maybe some runoff of when sokovia was
lifted
out of the earth yeah this mountainous
train we know this series shot
in uh the czech republic or at least in
reshoots there we may be revisiting
sokovia i think
there is so much fertile ground still in
that setting
that i'd love to explore in this series
especially if it allows us to i don't
know bring back ultron
into the mcu please but yeah this is
going to be globe trotting it looks like
some asian city
maybe shanghai actually that might be
tokyo because i think some set photos
have described seeing a
japanese demon on the back of a
motorcycle jacket and if we're talking
about who is the worthiest successor of
captain america's legacy sam
definitely makes a good case by just
jumping out of a plane
something we know captain america loves
to do and sam must see that and be like
damn it he's taking his moves
but yeah my general plot prediction for
this of course
this is set after the events of avengers
in game the world is piecing itself back
together but the sokovia accords are
still in effect
sam wilson bucky barnes not people the
government is too happy with so do they
want them to be their captain america
poster boy definitely not
and it looks like these two potential
captain america successors are
going to come across a group that either
is confirmed to be or something similar
to
the thunderbolts this is going to
include batroc the leaper it's going to
include songbird it's going to include a
couple other familiar faces you might
have seen before
and new ones as well and that group
might either be headed
up by or might be corrupted by baron
zemo who
is somehow now out of captivity and in
the comics baron zemo is the one who
kind of puts the thunderbolts together
it's kind of a
a phony superhero replacement team but
uh they're actually [ __ ] and then
eventually a lot of these become
redemptive characters in turn
on zemo leaving him as the odd man out
and even though uh this trailer doesn't
dig too much
into it i i feel like one of the themes
of the show is gonna deal with the whole
history of the captain america title
throughout american history i don't
think it's gonna shy away from some of
those racial themes and how captain
america is the you know uh
wonder bread boy scout but there's a
whole other side of the history that you
know more recent comics have delved into
with the black captain america and with
writers like malcolm spellman on the
staff this
is a theme that the show absolutely
should explore at least but yeah i know
there is way more under the surface uh
visual details that i'm missing right
now i'm going to spend way more time
digging into all the details of this
trailer i have a lot obviously that i'm
looking into this weekend we got a
reaction to loki that's already on the
channel make sure to go watch that
there's some stuff
i already caught there and a reaction to
the new wanda vision trailer that is
coming and breakdowns of all of these
things
we're double dipping on all of them and
yeah just my coverage on all the crazy
stuff
we learned just now a fantastic four
movies coming secret invasion is coming
ant-man in the wasp
in quantum mania what and if you're
wondering what i'm wearing this is new
rockstar's custom limited edition
mandalorian shirt this is this is away
but we're actually gonna do limited runs
of every series that we cover so we're
gonna release an exclusive shirt for one
division one for falcon winter soldier
in march when that comes out so if
you're interested in this stuff uh
you're gonna want to collect everything
by going to
check out what we have there's some
amazing gift options also subscribe to
new rockstars hit that notification bell
follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars on socials and uh stay tuned
because we got some crazy [ __ ] we're
gonna be talking about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you